But 5g is going to be tremendous a hundred times faster speeds and 4g,
if not quicker than that much lower latency,
quicker responsiveness of the network,
and also all kinds of applications we can't even dream of.
So we're just in the early stages right now,
the wireless carriers are doing some deployments in major cities,
including Los Angeles.
And we're hopeful that that's going to ramp up in the future.
I think we're going to have 92 commercial deployments across the country by the
end of this year.
So what's happening with 5g right now,
because I think now in LA it's in certain spots, I am seeing 5g.
It just pops up on my phone. And I remember, you know,
I was traveling a lot in the last year that certain cities I would get it and
I'd be like, Whoa, I didn't even know this was a thing.
So how does that actually work when you guys are trying to build a nationwide
network?
Yeah. So 5g is going to be tremendous a hundred times faster speeds and 4g,
if not quicker than that much lower latency and quicker responsiveness of the
network and also all kinds of applications we can't even dream of.
So we're just in the early stages right now,
the wireless carriers are doing some deployments in major cities,
including Los Angeles.
And we're hopeful that that's going to ramp up in the future.
I think we're going to have 92 commercial deployments across the country,
by the end of this year, many more are coming.
And so our goal is to put the building blocks in place for companies to innovate
that involves spectrum.
We're getting a lot more spectrum into the commercial marketplace,
held a big auction in January. Another one finished up in may.
Biggest auction in American history is going to be on December 10th and this
year alone,
we're going to push more spectrum in the commercial marketplace and just held by
every mobile broadband provider combined when it came to office.
And so huge influx of supply on the infrastructure side too.
We're modernizing our rules to recognize that small cells essentially
infrastructure.
That's no bigger than say that basketball shouldn't have to jump through the
same regulatory hoops as a 200 foot cell tower.
And that's the kind of thing that has real pop here in LA in particular,
just yesterday morning,
I was visiting a site where they're deploying these small cells in a lower
income neighborhood.
Thanks in part to the regulatory streamlining that we've done and the city of
LA, believe it or not as done, they have now had the real,
the city of Bay is helping. I've got to say,
mayor Garcetti has been a terrific partner on this issue.
Other cities have raised, uh, a little, few more roadblocks,
but those cities that are forward thinking that want their citizens to benefit
from 5g or adopting this more modern approach to infrastructure deployment.
So overall I think the United States is poised to lead,
but there are other countries too,
particularly China that would love to seize the lead for themselves.
And so we're in an implicit competition, I think,
with many countries and regions around the world.
Yeah. So right before we started,
we talked about this issue with how China deals with regulation differently and
their, their strengths and weaknesses to it. Can you explain that a bit?
Cause I think it's,
it's a really fascinating flip on the way we talk about a lot of these issues.
So China of course, is not a democracy. Uh, Beijing can dictate, uh,
not just what policy priorities the government should follow,
but also require all provinces, all localities to fall into line.
And so of course,
since they don't observe the same democratic niceties we do and this case,
they can simply feel that we want to lead the world in 5g.
That means we're going to pick the companies that create the equipment and
subsidize them.
We're going to make sure that our wireless carriers can deploy at scale and they
don't have to jump through these regulatory hoops.
And we are otherwise going to take the steps necessary to free up spectrum and
do the other things necessary for 5g success.
So that kind of sounds good at some level. Right, right. But there are,
of course, some concerns for those who shared democratic values,
such as the United States comparatively here,
we have not just federal regulatory approval,
that's required state and local regulatory approval.
That's required in many cases,
but also under a long-standing system that the FCC set up many years ago, uh,
any one of the 573 federally recognized Indian tribes also can have a bite at
the regulatory Apple.
So one of the points I've made is that let's try to modernize that framework to
say that there's a consistent level of regulation,
especially if you're a smaller company,
you don't have the lawyers and accountants and appliance officers to jump
through all of these four different layers of review.
And to the extent that capital is scarce and work crews don't have to be hired
in networks. Don't have to be built.
I don't want that innovative spirit to be directed to other parts of the world
where you can deploy at scale.
And that's part of the reason why we've been trying to work with localities like
LA to update that framework,
to make it more streamlined and E just easier and cheaper to build these
networks.
Well, China can just say, all right,
we're doing this and no local province can do anything about it.
And while that may work for now,
like it may make the process faster for now while you have to deal with the
local States and all that in the longterm,
it probably hurts their ability to innovate because it's all coming from the
top, right? You guys have more of a slog to fight through now,
but the hope is that you're creating the,
the groundwork sort of to allow as much competition as possible that through the
cell companies basically.
Exactly right.
And you're part of the reason why I want this regulatory modernization is not
just to be able to compete with other countries, but also because we recognize,
and this is one of the truths that hardly ever gets recognized in Washington,
that heavy handed regulation and multiple levels of regulation
disproportionately affect smaller companies.
It's the larger companies that don't have the compliance rates that have the
compliance resources that can jump through a lot of these hoops. Sure.
It will cost them money, but they actually have the resources to comply.
We don't want to squeeze out some of the smaller competitors.
And especially in the technology space,
we're trying to encourage a lot more companies to enter this space.
We haven't talked about space itself yet satellite companies and fixed wireless
companies. And some of these newer companies,
they might not be able to get off the ground.
If that regulatory framework is so onerous that they can't raise capital,
they can't hire the lawyers and they can never deploy a product.
Yeah. All right.
So I'm obviously gonna want to spend a lot more time talking about the pure tech
side of this and the Silicon Valley side, which is not, as you said,
everyone thinks it's sort of your job, but it's not quite your job, but wait,
let's just do the space thing for a minute because it's really interesting
because it quite literally is the next frontier, if not the final frontier,
how in the world do you sit down with people and you know, you have,
you have government people now trying to, uh,
deal with the ideas that Elon Musk and all of these people are coming in with.
We're privatizing a lot of the space stuff.
How do you even come to a basic place where you can say, well, you can,
you can kind of do this and I want you to be free, but we can't totally do that.
I mean, how does that conversation even it's, it's.
Fascinating. First of all, it's just intellectually fascinating to me.
I've always loved space. And, uh, the,
the innovation that's happening in space right now is just unprecedented.
I mean,
the launches they're able to do using reusable rockets have really decreased the
cost element to launching these things into space.
I literally sent a Tesla into just, just cause he could do it.
You know what I mean? Like you didn't have a regulation around that,
that you can just send a car into space. There was no, you didn't want to.
Yeah, no, it didn't fall within our purview, but yeah.
Things do fall within our purview.
So over the last two and a half years that we were the first administration to
approve what are called non geostationary, satellite orbit, constellations,
NGSS,
but essentially a lot of satellites that are being launched by companies like
space X and one web, and probably Kuyper Amazon in the future. Uh,
hundreds, if not thousands of these satellites in low earth, orbits,
not deep into space,
but lower in the earth orbit so that they can beam internet access services at a
speed and a price point that would be comparable to what you would get from a
terrestrial provider.
And my position here is very reflective of those principles.
We talked about from the beginning instead of preemptively regulating, deciding,
okay, you can launch, but all of you now, we're not going to let you do it.
Trying to pick a business case or a business plan.
That's going to work and letting them take the first crack.
We're taking a more market-based approach.
Let's allow all of them to launch in various stages,
using certain parameters for orbital safety and whatnot.
And we'll see what happens. Let's let the market,
the aggravated decisions of consumers decide which one will succeed.
And some of them might, you never know,
it could be a residential broadband product. Some of them are very different.
They want to do industrial internet of things.
I met recently with a company that just wants to deploy 150 satellites around
the globe and they want to sign up customers. Like you say,
the department of defense,
it has a military all around the world and they just need essentially low
bandwidth services just to let people know where the troops are at any given
point in time. W we want all of them to be able to succeed in space.
You don't really think about the orbital safety portion of this as you just
mentioned, but so that's just like, no matter what happens,
you guys almost always need another office to open, right. I mean,
is that sort of how it works? Because you're like, all right,
I want them to put the satellites up there.
We want to get people internet as fast as possible and as cheap as possible,
it's all good. And then someone probably walks in. It's like, you know,
we got to make sure these satellites aren't crashing into each other and then
you have to, what do you do? You do another study? I mean, do you,
what are you mapping out there? Even? That's a good question. So that's a,
it goes to the.
Early question. Yeah. So what if there were no regulations?
So here is where I think there is a base level of regulation.
That's really important, especially in the space environment,
for those of you who saw gravity. I mean, Sandra Bullock.
Right? Right.
We can't have these things just spinning around lacking each other. Exactly.
Well, because that stuff lasts for thousands of thousands of years,
especially if they don't descend in the atmosphere and burn up.
And so we want to make sure that that space environment is safe for everybody.
And so one of the things I kicked off about a year ago, let's see,
how should we update our orbital debris rules? They were first adopted in 2004,
but back then, we didn't have a lot of satellites up in space.
We're talking about a lot more stuff in space. And so accordingly,
I think our Overdale debris rules need to be updated.
So we're in the middle of conversation now about how should we think about
updating those rules requiring companies to be safe, uh,
should they have to deorbit on a certain schedule? You set certain technology,
that kind of things.
You'd prefer that everything has some sort of like time limit up there or
something.
So that eventually that it doesn't just become space garbage in
Futurama or something. Exactly.
The things we're thinking about is should there be a time limit,
should there be a built-in technology?
So some of these satellites can deorbit automatically after a certain period of
time, or if there is a failure, they will automatically deorbit, uh,
things like that.
And so ultimately we want to make sure that everybody's can succeed in space in
the long run. We don't want to, like I said, in any of these orbital slots,
if you have debris, that's a generational problem.
Not just a multi-year problem.
How much of this is sort of long-term thinking,
say the way you would talk about the climate change situation.
So it's sort of like, you can, you can plot a certain degree,
but no matter how much you plot other countries, I mean,
you just referenced China.
Other countries are just going to do things the way they want and how
complicated that makes your job.
It's meaning you could do everything exactly right. Perfectly right. And still,
if some other country decides to do whatever they want and you still,
you still have all of those problems.
It's that is a problem.
So there is a lot of international coordination that has to happen,
especially when it comes to orbital debris.
We're always working with some of the other countries agencies to make sure that
we're all on the same page.
And there are international organizations that deal specifically with this in
fact, shortly coming up and Egypt, there's a big, uh,
quadrennial every four years, they have this conference and, uh,
to talk about spectrum issues. And, uh, one of the issues is, uh,
what spectrum should be available for satellite companies. And, uh,
so in that context,
we're always talking about being on the same page on things like orbital debris
and, and spectrum allocation.
But I think you raise a really good point is that we could do everything
correctly,
but other countries are looking to take the lead on things like artificial
intelligence, machine learning, or blockchain or quantum computing.
And we don't have jurisdiction over all of it. But to the extent we can,
we want to make sure we advance the U S leadership because I do think that there
are some first mover advantages to countries and to sectors that really show
that they're willing to take the lead.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about tech,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our tech playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist, they're right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.